PROFESSOR: We start with
the stationary states.
In fact, stationary
states are going
to keep us quite busy for
probably a couple of weeks.
Because it's a place where you
get the intuition about solving
Schrodinger's equation.
So the stationary states are
simple and useful solutions
of the Schrodinger equation,
very nice and simple.
So what are they by definition?
Well, we begin
with a definition.
And the intuition of a
stationary state will follow.
See the word stationary
is not the same as static.
Stationary is something that
maybe it's kind of moving,
but things don't change.
Static is something
that's just not moving.
Stationary states
have time dependence.
It is very simple,
as we will see.
So, your definition
of a stationary state
has a factorized space
and time dependencies.
So this psi of x and t
is a stationary state.
If you can write it as a
product of a function of time
times a function of position.
And now, I will try to
be careful about this.
Wave functions that
have position and time
will have this
bar at the bottom.
Wave functions that don't
have x will not have it.
If I slip on that,
please let me know.
So this is a stationary
state, but a stationary state
has factorized space
and time dependencies
and solves the Schrodinger
equation-- the solution
of Schrodinger's equation.
So what we need to understand is
what this factorized dependence
tell us for the
Schrodinger equation.
So this stationary state
has time dependence.
But the thing that
makes them stationary
is that if you look
at some observable,
a Hermitian operator,
and you say,
OK, the state has
time dependence,
so maybe my observable
will have time dependence.
No.
The observables don't
have time dependence.
That is the nice thing
about stationary states.
So, what we call time
independent observables which
are all observables that
are familiar [INAUDIBLE]--
Hamiltonian, the
momentum, the precision,
the angular momentum.
Time independent observables
have no time dependence.
And it kind of looks simple
when you write it like that.
Time independent means
don't have time dependence.
But you've seen that d
dt of the expectation
value of x is equal to p
over m, or the sum of p
over m, the velocity.
And here it is-- a time
independent observable
that does have time dependence.
So the observable
is time independent,
but expectation value
have no time dependence
in their expectation values.
The time dependence
comes from the state--
the state, the psi of x
and t have time dependence,
and sometimes it just
doesn't drop out.
But for stationary states, it
will drop, as you will see.
So, time independent observables
have no time dependence
in their expectation values.
OK.
So enough of saying things.
And let's just get to them.
So we look at the
Schrodinger equation,
i h-bar d dt of
psi of x and t is
equal to h-bar psi of x and t.
And just to remind, this minus
h squared over 2m d second d x
squared plus V of x.
And I will consider states that
have just that at this moment.
Otherwise, it's not so easy
to get time-dependent--
to get stationary states.
If you have a potential
that has time dependence,
we kind of do the nice thing
that we're going to do.
So we're going to look only at
time independent potentials.
So, V of x, like this,
times psi of x and t.
OK.
So what we do next is
to simply substitute
the value of the wave function
into the differential equation
and see what we get.
So on the left
hand side, we will
get i h-bar The psi of x goes
out but you have d dt, Now
a normal derivative of g of t.
And now, this factor, H of
psi acts on these two things.
Imagine the function
of time times
the function of x sitting here.
Well, the function of
time can be moved out.
So the function of time can be
moved across the Hamiltonian
operator.
It doesn't do anything to it.
So we'll have g of t times
H-hat of the psi of x.
This is H-hat.
And because we had
no time dependence
in the potential,
our assumption,
this whole thing
is a function of x.
All right.
Next step.
Divide this whole equation
by the total wave function.
Divide by psi.
Well, if you divide by psi,
you cancel the middle psi here,
and you get the 1 over g.
So you get i h-bar 1
over g dg dt is equal--
on the right side, you
cancel the g and you get a 1
over psi of x H-hat psi of x.
And now you look
at this equation.
And this equation is saying
something very strange.
The left hand side is a
function of time only.
The right hand side is a
function of space only.
How can a function of time be
equal to a function of space?
The only way this can
be is if both are not
a function of what they
were supposed to be.
They're just numbers.
Any function of time cannot be
equal to a function of space,
in generality.
It just doesn't make sense.
So each side must be
equal to a constant,
and it's the same constant.
So each side, this is
all equal to a constant.
And we'll call the constant E.
And this E has units of energy.
E equal to be a real constant
with units of energy.
You can see the units
because the Hamiltonian
has units of energy.
And whatever psi units it has--
whatever every unit
psi has, they cancel.
Here, whatever units
g has, they cancel.
And h-bar over time
is units of energy,
like in energies
equal h-bar omega.
So it has units of energy.
The only thing that you
may be could say, why real.
Quantum mechanics
loves complex numbers.
So why don't we
put the complex E?
We'll see what trouble
we get if you choose
something that is complex.
So here we go.
It's a real quantity
to be-- let's
do it real for the time being.
And let's solve
the first equation.
The left hand side, i h-bar dg
dt is now equal to gE, or E,
where E is a number and
g is a function of time
from where g of p is
equal to constant E
to the minus iEt over h-bar.
Let's just check
it works correctly.
It's a first order
differential equation.
Just one function
of integration.
If you guess the answer,
must be the answer.
And that's the time dependence
of a stationary state.
It's exponential
minus iEt over h-bar.
What about the other equation?
The other equation has become
H psi of x equals E psi of x.
Or, we should write at least
once, minus h squared over 2m--
did I make a mistake?
No, I didn't-- d
second dx squared--
I got this normal
derivatives here
because this is just
a function of x--
plus V of x psi is
equal to E psi of x.
This is the same equation
that I'm boxing twice,
because it's written
in those two ways.
And both ways are
very important.
And this is part of solving
for stationary state.
You've solved for g of t.
The time dependence
was easy to solve for,
but the x dependence is
complicated, in general.
There, you have to do some work.
You have to solve a
differential equation.
It's not that easy.
So many people-- most people--
call this the time independent
Schrodinger equation.
So that's the time independent
Schrodinger equation,
where H psi equal E psi.
And as you can imagine, solving
this differential equation can
be challenging, or
sometimes very interesting
because it may be that, as
far as the first equation
is concerned, of
what we did here,
we don't know what
this number E is.
But it may be that the
only reasonable solutions
that this equation has
are for some values of E.
The analogy with
matrices should tell you
that's probably what's
going to happen.
Because you remember eigenstates
and eigenvalues of matrices
are peculiar numbers.
If you have a matrix,
they're peculiar eigenvalues.
So this equation is an
eigenfunction equation.
And it's possible that
it has the solution
for some particular
values of the energy.
Let me write the
whole solution then.
If you've solved
these two things,
the whole solution
psi of x and t
is now a constant
times psi of x times
e to the minus iEt over
h-bar, where this psi of x
solves this equation.
So this is the stationary state.
How about normalizing
the stationary state?
Can we do that?
Well, if we try
to normalize it--
psi star of x and t
and psi of x and t dx,
and you set this equal to 1.
This should be the
case, because this
should be interesting solutions
of the Schrodinger equation.
We expect that we could
do particles with them.
And we can start wave packets
or peculiar states with them.
And let's see what we get here.
Maybe I should know.
I'm really [INAUDIBLE].
I'm going to erase
that constant C here.
Since we want to
normalize this, we
will think of this as
a normalization of psi.
When we try to
normalize psi, we'll
be normalizing middle
psi, as you will see here.
There's no need to put
that constant there.
So what do we get here?
We get integral dx
psi star of x and t,
so you have psi of x star.
And now you could say it's
E to the iEt over h-bar.
That's the complex conjugate.
Now, on the other
hand, suppose--
I'll do this this way.
[INAUDIBLE] of
this other term is
psi of x into the
minus iEt over h-bar.
And now the good
thing about this, you
see this integral should be
normalized to 1 to make sense.
And it's a great thing that
the time dependence drops out.
And it would not have dropped
out if the energy had not
been real.
If the energy was
not real, I would
have had to put here E start.
And here I would have
had E star minus E
and some function of time.
And how can a function
of time be equal to 1?
Would be a problem.
We would not be able to
normalize this wave function.
So E must be real
because otherwise we
don't cancel this time
dependence, which happily,
when it cancels,
it just tells you
that the integral dx of
psi star of x psi of x
must be 1, which is
a very nice thing.
So in a stationary state,
the normalization condition
for a full time dependent
stationary state
is that the spacial
part is normalized.